ce que vous étiez venus regarder là où
merci pour les élections mais y'a rien
du tout alors on ne sait pas oui les
prunay le gillon liens peuvent chercher
en vain les affiches électorales
ils ne voteront ni le 15 ni le 22 mars
car dans les communes de plus de 1000
habitants il n'est pas possible de
composer une liste entre les deux tours
le village est pourtant équipée de
commerce de quelques services publics
d'une médiathèque d'employés communaux
mais pas de candidat ça c'est bizarre
quand même
bon moi j'aurais peut-être pu me
présenter aussi peut-être mais il ya des
personnes que je pensais que sont la
commune était capable de reprendre le
flambeau mais bon bah c'est vrai que
c'est aujourd'hui c'est tellement
contraignant que peut-être ils ont
peut-être fait un peu peur aussi
en 2008 trois listes s'étaient présentés
en 2014 il n'y en avait plus qu'une et
cette fois aucun des quinze conseillers
municipaux sortants a voulu repartir à
commencer par le maire
épuisée par deux mandats pendant
lesquelles il a en plus conserver son
activité professionnelle il avait
annoncé depuis longtemps son retrait il
ya deux ans j'avais annoncé c'est cette
fin de mandature et donc j'avais demandé
bien nous vint le temps du aux élus en
place de sa de savoir s'ils voulaient il
souhaitait repartir
donc j'ai organisé cette réunion au
travers desquelles chacun a pu
s'exprimer et progressivement
peut-être que le temps était néfaste à
cette position
les élus se sont écartés du fait de
vouloir repartir et constituer une liste
et nous sommes arrivés
mécaniquement à cette date butoir la
date butoir est maintenant repoussée de
trois mois pendant lesquels trois
fonctionnaires désignés par la
préfecture vont gérer les affaires
courantes et organiser de nouvelles
élections
le maire sortant promet de tout faire
pendant ce délai pour trouver un
successeur
car s'il n'y a à nouveau pas de candidat
la commune seraient obligées de
fusionner avec l'une de ses voisines